I think the problem Dave is or where we
should start is the normalcy bias
um
the normalcy bias gets humans into
trouble it also saves our lives on day
to day on day to day you need you need
um
you know we we are we are we have
trained ourselves to look for dangers
and if we were looking for dangers we
would find them all the time and we'd be
freaking out all the time so we have
What's called the normalcy bias that
kind of fits into the normal pattern so
I got it and so you don't even really
think of that threat
um you know in your frontal cortex so
on September 11th is a great example
what happened there was a lot of the
people that could have gotten out were
making their way down the stairs out of
one of the towers and then they turned
around and went back up because they had
to turn off their computer they had to
they forgot their purse or whatever they
just assumed they were coming back
because
it was too big to handle an airplane
going through their building they it
just it didn't compute so the normalcy
bias to keep you calm happens
that's what's happening in our world
today people are just pretending and I
think it's natural that all of this is
normal and it will it's still within the
normal parameters and so I don't
nothing's really going to happen and
that is we are right now in the stairs
of the twin towers and it's coming down
you just have to prepare and be aware of
it otherwise it's chaos and panic
we are we are in the midst of of a
technological Revolution and you know
many people we can do all the Sci-Fi
references people basically would say
you know Skynet is on the machines have
sort of taken over already the amount of
people that will see this very video it
really is beholden to algorithms and
machine learning and God knows what else
but before we dive into all of that you
for a long time I give you a lot of
credit my friend you've been right about
a lot of things way before and and I
told you when we first met well before
we had never worked together anything
else I would watch you on I think first
on CNBC and then on Fox you'd have the
chalkboard and I'd be like I can't tell
if this guy's completely insane
absolutely hilarious a genius a lunatic
like all of that stuff but it turns out
your track record
yeah exactly exactly that's what your
next book that's what my book about you
will be on uh but but in essence though
with all of the the Blackboard stuff and
pointing to okay here are the people
doing this and this is what's going on
here you've pretty much been right
within within like a certain set of
limits you've been pretty much right
about most of the stuff
I'm really wrong on timing
um that's where I really get it wrong
um however it's not hard to figure it
out it's really not
um I I will tell you anything that I got
right uh I think
comes more from God than me anything
that I got wrong is definitely
um but uh
you have to just take people
at their word and the first time that I
was really right about something kind of
profoundly scary was September 11th and
I it was uh August of 99 maybe and I was
on the air at WABC and
uh it had to be earlier than that
because Clinton was still in office and
uh and he had just bombed the aspirin
Factory if you remember that and what he
was doing he was targeting Osama Bin
Laden I couldn't even pronounce his name
I'd never even heard of it Osama being
being Laden I think I called him and uh
I said uh look I'm no fan of Clinton
but
this guy is scary this this is one thing
that maybe we should pay attention to
and I got so much pushback from the
audience and I said guys
he's saying he's going to kill us
take him at his word okay you're wrong
if he if he doesn't but at least you're
prepared in case he does and I said uh
within 10 years There Will Be Blood
bodies and buildings in this city and it
will have his name on it if you don't
pay attention to him you just have to
take people at their word
yeah and geez yeah well you certainly
turned out right on that one and and
you've been ballparking a lot of the
other stuff that is we're going through
right now your last book on the great
reset uh really what's happening
everywhere in terms of this giant
globalist government that seems to
perhaps control both parties right now
but certainly control the Democrat Party
and everything else is that is that a
good place to start as we enter this
dark future just sort of what's going on
politically here at the moment without
getting into just what happened today or
yesterday in case you're dead by the
time we post this and I don't wanna
you know and then I I would say you know
something like that whole Kamala Harris
taking office thing was a surprise and
then it didn't happen yeah anyway
um the um
I think the problem Dave is or where we
should start is
the normalcy bias
um
the normalcy bias gets humans into
trouble it also saves our lives on day
to day on day to day you need you need
um
you know we we are we are we have
trained ourselves to look for dangers
and if we were looking for dangers we
would find them all the time and we'd be
freaking out all the time so we have
What's called the normalcy bias that
kind of fits into the normal pattern so
I got it and so you don't even really
think of that threat
um you know in your frontal cortex so
on September 11th is a great example
what happened there was a lot of the
people that could have gotten out were
making their way down the stairs out of
one of the towers and then they turned
around and went back up because they had
to turn off their computer they had to
they forgot their purse or whatever they
just assumed they were coming back
um because
it was too big to handle an airplane
going through their building they it
just it didn't compute so the normalcy
bias to keep you calm happens
that's what's happening in our world
today people are just pretending and I
think it's natural that all of this is
normal and it will it's still within the
normal parameters and so I don't
nothing's really gonna happen and that
is we are right now in the stairs of the
twin towers and it's coming down you
just have to prepare and be aware of it
otherwise it's chaos and panic you know
it's so it's so interesting to me that
you're framing it that way because you
know I'm very proud to say that when
when covet happened I was very early on
on being skeptical like once the the 15
day thing hit when they said 15 days to
stop the the spread on day 16 I was
basically done and the reason I was done
is because of a word that you just said
everywhere every news organization every
commercial every uh Public Service
Announcement kept saying the new normal
it's the new normal and I was like wait
a minute wait a minute you guys just
told us 15 days we'll be good to go and
then overnight The New Normal so so that
has something I think to do with another
word you mentioned earlier about timing
that these things sort of happen in a
way
where we don't realize how much we're
giving away as we're giving it away
because we are geared to Safety in the
herd and that's why the individuals the
Preppers and everybody else the people
who have already made a move to a safer
area or one with a stronger Community
sense
they're the ones that are going to
survive I mean Dave I think I asked you
at one point
maybe a couple of years ago
at what point do we realize or at what
point do we become the German Jew
that just kept saying it's not going to
get worse than this uh I mean it may not
get worse than this I pray to God it
doesn't get worse to this but we are
we're traveling the same road if you're
looking for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics instead of
mindless dribble check out our politics
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics watch
our full episode playlist all right over
here and to get notified of all future
videos be sure to subscribe and click
the notification Bell